Okay, the time has come for me to
address the elephant, or more literally,
the dog in the room.
[Music]
If you've watched any of my previous
videos, no doubt you've seen some
attention-seeking hounds walting about,
jumping on the couch behind me, yawning,
mad dogging me, and being overall
intrusive. Here are just a few examples.
Is a religious duty upon Muslims in
general. Jihad must continue to be done
until the whole world is under the rule
of Islam. Islam must completely be made
over day when a Muslim man plowed his
truck into people in New Orleans,
killing 15 and wounding dozens. The same
thing actually happened a few days
earlier on December 20th. Talib Abdul
Mosen, a Muslim man from Saudi Arabia
with a long history of pretending to be
a critic of Islam and a convert to
Christianity, etc. All right, let's talk
about Saladin Salah Houdin, the great
Muslim hero. It was hardly to be
expected that the triumphant Spaniards
and Portuguese
would stop Christian pastor and his
church in Turkey was exposed. 14 Muslim
suspects
solely on these primary sources of
Islam, Christians concluded that
Muhammad was a demon-possessed false
prophet who had very obviously concocted
a creed to justify the worst
and continue to be rei to be relied on
by Jews. Islam does.
Islam does the complete opposite.
In the midst of all the turmoil in the
Middle East, a prominent Egyptian sheh
is calling on Donald Trump to follow
guidance.
Yes, in a video, Sheikh Mustafa Alawi
made the following summons.
quote, "A message to Trump, the great
one of America, peace to whoever follows
guidance.
Submit and all will go well for you and
sprinkled with holy water and salt, so
that what had once been the devil's
layer was made a church of Jesus,
as I was saying, and those are just the
ones you've seen. Then there are the
ones that were so out of hand, I had to
completely redo them." So, so you can,
as you can see,
Yeah. Okay.
>> All right.
>> Calm down, man. Just get down,
>> noob.
Down.
So, I'm talking and then Yeah. So,
that's why
[Music]
down. All right. Here's the thing.
My office, this office here where I make
my videos, that recliner behind me is
where I wrote my last four books, by the
way, has also become this dog's default
den. And trying to keep him out while I
record, as I have tried, only invites a
cacophony of howling and yowling. So, I
just keep him in and hope he doesn't
interrupt. That said, lately, however,
whenever I record, he's taken to sitting
right down there under my desk where he
is right now. So, for all of you
wondering where he's gone, the answer is
nowhere. He's right here as I speak, mad
dogging me as usual. No doubt he'll
start making cameos again once the mood
takes him. As for those of you, and you
seem to be many, who have expressed a
general interest in the dog, here's his
backstory. First, you should know that
although I've had dogs before, mostly in
my youth, I eventually concluded that
I'm not much of a dog person. I've
always liked them well enough, but
usually from afar. The drooling, the
licking, the accidents, the barking, the
noise, and the overall responsibility
required in properly keeping a dog.
These have traditionally been a little
too much for me. At least I admit it.
That's better, I think, than biting off
more than one can chew by, for example,
getting a dog and keeping it in a crate
for most of its existence because you're
always away at work, which was another
consideration for me. Instead, I've
always been a cat person, believe it or
not. And since as long as I can
remember, have always had a cat in my
keeping. I've got pictures here
somewhere back when I was six or seven
with some hapless cat dangling over my
arms. And they're almost always an
orange male tabby for some reason. Cats
are, as they say, chill and easy to take
care of. They have an I'll leave you
alone if you leave me alone attitude,
which I can definitely appreciate.
Here's Leo, my longest standing pet and
therefore the goat who I had for about
16 years until just 3 years ago when he
sadly met his demise. This, by the way,
is not Leo, but Aie, his predecessor
from well over 20 years ago. See what I
mean about orange tabies? Anyway, Leo
first started getting annoyed with our
setup some 7 years ago when another cat,
a calico kitten that I subsequently
named Cali, popped out from under my car
hood one day, becoming another default
pet. Then, some four years ago, for
reasons I will not get into, this dog
was more or less thrust upon me as a
puppy. Now, I could have said no, but I
gave in to my humanitarian impulses,
figuring, "What the heck? Let's give
this dog business another go." For the
record, the last time I owned a dog, a
German Shepherd named Strider, was back
in the '9s, in my early 20s.
Incidentally, if Leo the cat, got
annoyed with the introduction of that
other cat, Callie. He really came undone
on learning he had to share his premises
with this dog. As you can see in this
picture taken on the very first day I
took the dog in. See him as a pup? Yeah.
Well, zoom in and take a look at the
stalker lurking in the background. Look
at him. It's like he's saying, "How
could you, man? We had a good thing
going. Why'd you go and ruin it like
that?" Anyway, since then, I don't know
if it's this dog personally or if my
disposition has changed with age, but
I've grown quite fond of him, and he of
me. He definitely keeps me company
during those long daily hours when I sit
on that recliner, pounding away on my
keyboard.
I mean, what joy to look up from my
keyboard only to be confronted by this.
All right, here's a much better image.
And he forces me to leave the computer
and take him out for walks in the
wilderness, which is definitely a
welcome break. If you don't know, as I
didn't, but learned the hard way, this
breed, Australian Shepherds, are
apparently plum loco, full of energy,
though he's finally calming down now
that he's over four years old. The first
couple of years, he was a total lunatic.
Oh, as for his name, you may find its
etmology amusing. So, as you might have
guessed, I'm a big fan of mythology, and
several of my pets have been named after
mythological figures. When I got this
dog, I thought the name of the Egyptian
jackal god, Anubis, might be a good fit.
Here, incidentally, is one of my Anubai
statues from that collection of historic
statues I've collected over the years
behind me. As often happens, it wasn't
long before I preferred to pronounce two
rather than three syllables. And so
Anubis quickly became Nubis and then
Noobie. I think you may be seeing where
this is going. And yes, before long a
one-cllable name became so much easier
on the tongue than two. And thus he
became noob. All right, so look, at the
time I had no idea that noob was an
actual insult amongst, I guess, gamers.
Apparently it's gamer slang for newbie,
as in someone painfully unskilled and
embarrassing to be around. Anyway, I
only learned this recently when one day
in a park where I thought I was all
alone and was accordingly yelling at the
top of my lungs, "Noob, noob, get over
here," that some insulent chuckling
teenagers approached. One of them, in
the tone people usually reserve for
explaining what a fax machine is to
their grandparents, informed me that uh,
you know, that's like an insult, dude.
So, yeah, it turns out I've been
publicly berating my dog with gamer
trash talk. He still came when called,
though. loyal noob. Anyway, so there it
is. He is figuratively and literally the
noob. Okay, if you've made it this far,
I'll assume you like dogs and pets in
general. So, I'll end this video with a
few more pictures, seeing how that
camera seeeking hound is for once
missing in action down here, even though
this video is about him. Here's the noob
as a pup. Now, I didn't get him when he
was that young, but rather when he was
about 2.5 months, as in these pictures.
Here's a comparison shot with my hand to
give you an idea of how he's grown. Here
am I trying to eat in peace and being
badgered by both dog and cat.
Here's the cat trying to be a feronic
era statue.
By the way, this cat is always much
friendlier in the winter months user.
Then there was this. I heard a bang,
opened my door, and was confronted by
this spectacle. Don't worry, the cat was
fine. They were just playing around.
Okay, now you know the full story of the
noob. that dog which no doubt you'll be
seeing and hearing again. Bye.
[Music]